buon pomeriggio a tutti la mia onesta
un'esperienza proattiva quindi proverò a
raccontare cosa sto facendo da un paese
della calabria
allora vi racconto il caso dell'azienda
che rappresento è un lanificio po strano
avere un'azienda tessile in calabria io
sono come ci è stato detto il migliore o
rappresenta la quarta generazione di una
famiglia di imprenditori tessili sono un
uomo prestato all'architettura è un
architetto prestato ad impresa come
disse in ogni strada qualche anno fa
scrivendo di me
disse che ho scelto di fare l'architetto
per vocazione
dovevo fare anche l'imprenditore per
destino e allora io sono in abito in
calabria e lanificio e a soveria
mannelli nella periferia della periferia
di questo sud perché è importante
ricordarsi dove si è il gioco
geolocalizzare questa storia ed è una
storia fatta di uomini di ingranaggi
quindi di mondo analogico di mondo
meccanico anche di mondo molto lontano
dalla tecnologia quella che siamo
abituati in questo momento a vivere e di
territorio
il mio bisnonno nel 1873
osservando il territorio i valori le
possibilità e soprattutto la presenza di
una pecora di una razza la cosiddetta
gentile
tra l'altro la riconosciuta come gentile
di puglia una merinos incredibile che
pare gli spagnoli abbiano portato qui
durante la dominazione qualcun altro
dice che i romani portarono queste
stesse pecore in spagna e poi ce l'hanno
riportate qui in ogni caso avevamo un
grande patrimonio e da questo patrimonio
come tante storie impresa
quest'uomo in un paese sperduto della
sila ebbe l'intuizione di valorizzare da
un punto di vista del business lo
sfruttamento o comunque la
valorizzazione di questa materia prima e
questa storia naturalmente come tante
storie imprenditoriali non ha una vita
infinita perché ci sono delle condizioni
di contesto e la gentile di puglia è
stata una di queste condizioni di
contesto che non sono infinite o che
probabilmente come società non riusciamo
a tenere sul lungo periodo
negli anni 70 queste pecore furono
completamente cambiate
la società di riferimento stravolta
anche nello stile di vita e quindi tutto
quello che era stato dentro la vocazione
imprenditoriale dell'anief i cio 1.0 in
pochi anni si sgretolò insieme a
un sistema proto industriale
che ha contato 40 aziende come la nostra
cioè tutte dal basso
allora cosa c'entro io in questa storia
io ero l'ultimo della famiglia che
doveva occuparsene
però nel 1998 avendo questa diciamo
nostalgia del futuro perché questa è una
storia di tradizione ma è anche una
storia di futuro perché se continuiamo a
parlare del nostro passato in chiave
retorica probabilmente non ne usciremo
e allora ho pensato che dalla fabbrica o
comunque da quello che ne era rimasto
perché ci furono 20 anni di stop
imprenditoriale da quel luogo tra
virgolette di archeologia industriale si
potesse riattivare un meccanismo
virtuoso di impresa su diciamo con una
visione completamente nuova
sicuramente il territorio dove siamo non
è indifferente
noi sappiamo che il food è uno di quei
settori che non può prescindere dal
luogo dove si fa l'agrifood a questa
condizione fondamentale il tessile
probabilmente non lo è più ma speriamo
lo sarà di nuovo ma immaterialmente il
fatto che noi siamo a 1000 metri sul
livello del mare
questa è un'immagine della sila sembra
un paese del nord europa ma è la potenza
frattale di quello che ci sta intorno e
che probabilmente noi non abbiamo gli
occhi molte volte per per capire è
fondamentale e in più io avevo una cosa
in materiale che gli altri miei parenti
non avevano capito questo questo primato
il pil primato di essere la più antica
fabbrica tessile della calabria cioè
l'opificio esistente con la più antica
storia alle spalle
e allora cosa ho fatto ho preso della
ferraglia perché tale è e tale era per
tutto il resto della mia famiglia e lo
sublimata l'ho fatta diventare
patrimonio industriale c'è stata una
grossa operazione di comunicazione alle
spalle questo era il logo dell'azienda
prima del mio intervento
noi abbiamo un cognome leo quindi dal
latino leo leonis per cui era normale
che ci fosse un logo che fosse un leone
e allora io ho fatto o declassato
all'azienda pecora e mio padre non è
stato molto contento
mio padre ha 93 anni io ne ho 40 è nelle
nostre mani c'è scritto tradizione
innovazione la foto mi taglia la testa
per una questione proprio tecnica
scenica per far capire che forse
potremmo potrei avere i capelli ma non
ce li ha e l'innovazione la tradizione
sono i due ingredienti questa storia non
sono alternativi anzi sono molto
complementari e questa immagine dice che
non necessariamente l'innovazione nelle
mani dei giovani e la tradizione nelle
mani della generazione precedente perché
sono la sono due facce della stessa
medaglia la tradizione el'innovazione
che ce l'ha fatta e quelli innovazione
che in qualche modo convince molte
persone e si stratifica e quindi il modo
per conservare la tradizione e la
trasformazione è l'unico vero modo forse
paradossale di andare avanti conservando
un codice riconoscibile e allora nel
tempo
con questa fabbrica di lana comunque
fabbrica tessile con tanti processi
dentro e con molto bob sole scienza ci
sarebbe stato impossibile riprendere il
business cercando ostinatamente di
rifare quello che faceva mio nonno che
aveva fatto per decenni mio padre ho
cominciato a capire che in questa
azienda doveva trasformarsi trasformarsi
dopo nel modello di management e quindi
una visione nuova di un software nuovo
su un hardware obsoleto è un po una
storia di trans genia se volete e il
rapporto impresa e cultura per noi è
stato fin dall'inizio un binomio
fondamentale
due mondi che il novecento aveva
allontanato in maniera molto netta e
molto forte e io ho capito almeno
quindici anni fa che forse era arrivato
il momento di portare a sintesi
naturalmente in un mood del tempo perché
c'erano tante altre aziende che stavano
cominciando a fare questo corto circuito
e allora il nostro patrimonio
cioè le vecchie macchine il nostro
processo obsoleto
piano piano si è trasformato in
strumenti per la riorganizzazione di
tutti quei valori che poi qualche anno
dopo anno generato la nuova impresa
diciamo una specie di start up sulle
ceneri di questa di questa storia
imprenditoriale comunque piena di valori
e da una parte le vecchie macchine che
sono ancora il cuore di parte della
produzione sono diventate il museo di
impresa però un museo che non si osserva
ma che si utilizza come una specie di
fab lab ante litteram e poi una serie di
strumenti culturali tra cui un festival
che è durato dieci anni per con il quale
tre giorni durante l'estate aprivamo a
tutti i linguaggi contemporanei più più
avanzati pensate che la prima volta c'è
in paese la voce che girava era ma
questo è stato mandato a scuola
se questi sono i risultati c'è qualche
problema e quindi diciamo la fabbrica ha
visto performer grafici musicisti di
musica elettronica teatro sperimentale
per tantissime notti durante le estati
da tutte le parti dell'europa e quindi
questo ha permesso di fare un salto
diciamo dalla dal cuore della fabbrica
di territorio al brand cioè costruire
qualcosa che nella sua capacità in
materiale potesse andare molto oltre
dal territorio fisico in cui si trova e
quindi le prime cose che ci hanno
aiutato a fare questa cosa qui sono
stati la finale del premio guggenheim
cioè quando io avevo forse poco più di
vent'anni partecipare a questo questo
premio capi in quel momento che cosa
stava facendo
e probabilmente che era nel mood del
tempo che si stava si stava per rivelare
e dopo di questa cosa sono cominciate
tutte le connessioni derivanti da questa
costruzione dal basso di networking
quindi andrea branzi ci ha scelto per
new italian design domus
io da architetto diciamo nel 2007 ho
avuto un progetto su domus non è un
progetto di architettura ma il progetto
della gemmo della fabbrica sei pagine
mio padre sfogliando questa questa
rivista
la prima la seconda la terza mi disse
tutto qui di cobham bella monografia poi
arriverà e così poi il prodotto l'adi
design index il compasso d'oro cioè
tutta una serie di sistemi di
reputazione che naturalmente per
un'azienda micro di territorio e con un
background molto limitato da un punto di
vista di apertura al mercato sono stati
un fattore di moltiplicazione di
visibilità estremo diciamo l'ultima cosa
per esempio che abbiamo avuto come come
sistema di riconoscibilità e l'essere
stati inseriti in questa mostra mostra
della fondazione rosselli che ha sede a
roma si chiamava quale industria per
quale futuro quindi una grossa
riflessione sul futuro del
manifatturiero italiano e noi insieme a
tante altre aziende molto più grandi di
noi siamo stati selezionati con le
nostre esperienze e allora tutta questa
genesi in realtà permesso nel 2008 di
attivare di nuovo l'impresa quindi in un
altra latitudine in un altro contesto
probabilmente ci sarebbero state due
altre situazioni o l'azienda negli anni
si sarebbe evoluta a tal punto da poter
ritornare ad investire sulla propria
memoria ma non è stato il nostro caso
nell'altro caso ancora ci sarebbe stato
come dire una comunità talmente
affezionata al valore immateriale di
questo luogo che ne avrebbe fatto un
museo classico nessuna dei due delle due
cose sono successe ma ne è successo a
una terza probabilmente molto più
interessante e molto piu dista stimolo
per quello che noi dovremmo fare come
comunità cioè capire con quello che
abbiamo
anche se poco e sembra non utile o fuori
dalle logiche della novità che cosa
possiamo fare e allora tutta
l'esperienza diciamo di imprese cultura
quindi di management culturale dei dieci
anni antecedenti sono serviti nel 2008
con pochissime risorse quindi con
pochissimi soldi pubblici
tra l'altro nella nella vecchia fabbrica
non c'è mai stato un e un euro ha una
lira di soldi pubblici spesi quindi
capite che cosa significa poter
continuare a mettere a valore materiali
e immateriali qualcosa di ammortizzato
per la comunità ed è ripartita l'azienda
su un posizionamento completamente
diverso mettendo a valore tutto il
processo di produzione sia quello
storico sia un pò di innovazione
tecnologica che è stata introdotta per
cominciare a sperimentare anche su quel
fronte
perché il problema del linguaggio sul
prodotto è un problema legato
essenzialmente l'interpretazione dei
processi possono essere macchine
nell'ottocento ma possono essere anche
macchine a controllo numerico è chiaro
che la differenza anche di differenziali
di competitività in questo momento è
legato all'interpretazione e quindi
questa storia senza prodotto sarebbe una
bella storia da raccontare ai turisti ma
noi ambiamo al mercato
e allora abbiamo fatto dell'errore una
cifra stilistica un campo di indagine
anche etico
facciamo un sacco di di sperimentazione
ci divertiamo perché pensiamo che
processo e prodotto siano un connubio
indissolubile per il rapporto
che porta a quest idea di essere
imperfettamente belli e forse noi
meridionali siamo in perfettamente belli
io sicuramente e quindi diciamo tutta
questa questa cosa per esempio noi
facciamo un prodotto che si chiama punto
pecora che il nostro prodotto icona adi
design index selezione composto compasso
d'oro che è il nostro logo ridotto alla
dimensione minima riconoscibile da un po
triste della risoluzione della macchina
quindi è un lavoro possibile solo se si
conosce perfettamente il processo per
cui l'attenzione al processo è
sicuramente maggiore rispetto al design
di prodotto esistono sul web
molte molte referenze per cui chi vorrà
approfondire potrà farlo io sono un
posto disposizione anche dopo o quando
vorrete per per avere altre altre
delucidazioni
ma mi piaceva lasciarvi con questa idea
che la tradizione non è il culto della
cenere ma la custodia del fuoco perché
abbiamo bisogno di cercare intorno a noi
l'innesco di questa nuova passione e le
risposte sono molto vicine ci abbiamo
tantissimo da riconvertire e tantissimo
valore da rimettere a campionamento il
fatto che oggi un gruppo di ragazzi
giovani capaci abbiano avuto la
lungimiranza di ragionare su un tema
come questo sì ci fa capire che noi
dobbiamo darci e avere e pretendere un
futuro che sia un futuro sicuramente più
interessante di quello che qualcuno ha
disegnato per noi e allora un giorno
probabilmente anche le pecore potranno
volare grazie